as an expensive river over you now
so why is that as you do
so did you ever get angry over what
happened you Jerry yeah no they say the
pack anything against it if you could if
you could say something to the person
that shot you what would you say to them
that's the only way isn't anybody said
is it business or lives
what do you wish the what do you wish
the world understood better what do you
think a lot of people don't quite
understand that stated nice
the lesson you let's get you into the
highs and lows ups and downs it's here
if you didn't say those sign some time
you have to wait
you go to church every Sunday it's nice
to go reach out of street that is to go
there I was raised with church was no go
ahead go to Jason oh so you've always
been religious but Leslie is good
sandy school setting school boy to black
yeah did you find that religious
background helped you deal with what
happened to you Tiffany this yes cuz
your attitude today is so light and
pleasant and yes I keep my trusty guy
that your amazing guy I mean you're I
think your attitude is an inspiration to
so many people yeah reasonably bad world
valid excuse me excuse me man will
healthy because this right here brother
I give up and like you done I can't give
goodbye you let me
did you ever do drugs during your life
what we you smoked weed yeah you never
did never did crack or anything heavier
no because I had heard a story the but
the reason you got shot was because of a
crack dead and somebody shot you and it
was some different story yeah well good
thing I broke into my house and took a
Jewish that'd be good enough Oh
people love to hear stories right
they'll have to make stories oh they
said you were in a gang yeah but you
were never in a gang oh this is what I'm
learning that with social media is
people love to create little stories for
whatever reason and there's multiple
reasons for it but people love to create
stories to defame people to tarnish
their image to - you know it's fueled by
jealousy or fueled by something who
knows but ya know because you said
somebody they live in the apartment
building is you know there's always some
credible how do they know ya know ya
know I'm learning that just as the story
is voice doesn't mean it's true
well you ain't all oh yeah
I was drugged me om you know and so
religion plays a huge role in your life
right definitely live a happy life just
be very warm
yeah a little movie Teddy strong guy
taking
that would beYOU seem like we look
beautiful
you ever get depressed you ever get
depressed that way like just feeling
down feeling like you your your your
life is not working out the way you
wanted it to you pity yourself you feel
like you're a victim I don't hear any of
that I've talked to you how many times
now countless times yeah I've never
heard any of that from you that's I'm
just asking these questions if my
viewers will be like you got to be
depressed sometimes you got to get angry
you got to be something but I know
you're bad that that because what
happened to me just just because you're
human you go yeah you mean the UVA the
Ramanujan yeah like oh yeah I will do
the same way you do that including the
everything yeah everything that's
beautiful attitude thank you
that's it buddy news your minds are
gonna present there you're lucky that
the whatever part of your brain you lost
it's lovely yeah it's not it's not
really a hitch what if we put it what
how are you impaired cuz you walk you
talk and you think your attitude is
great I mean what do you think what has
a the place is very short
your patients are short did I say join
the club yeah this is my stimulant see
your wife stay with Liberty and let me
walk [ __ ] temperature sizes it Oh your
stability this is you go yeah yeah see I
take all my food grains my foot foot
ways out but boy it was my back way as
me there is your bed way to choose your
home back pictures have you seen moving
on steps look the back way yeah well a
bunch of fight if you gotta change in
any for the grounds back way
[Music]
what was the best time you're like
really to BYU you went to BYU
hey that's what they hold high school
play the best ballplayers United States
with Bo you - we play eternally that's
that's where I want mister immediately
but he wanted a is playing with the
basketball then I did it was that Danny
Ainge yeah
anyplace ball for Telugu J's but you
work out right so investors me that
baseball you can play that's one yeah
yeah you're a great basketball player
yeah yeah scholarship school
oh so your grades are not so great yes
but you're tall enough 64 yes New York
Athletic you've lost some weight though
you told me yeah did we back yeah so
your life today you you have housing
yeah it's a nice little place you got
nice building I mean it's it's it's
still at Skid Row housing thing but it's
one of the nicest ones in the
neighborhood I think yeah yeah well
anybody secured you yeah very secure
hard to get in that door move on I just
saw him coming to meet Jerry and they
let me get better than that
Jerry down there yeah what do you think
you need in life I got guys with I don't
see right solutely hey give me a regular
that's beneath you see that let's go get
your radio right now I'm gonna get your
radio okay yeah
that's easy as it was no play when I get
so you can carry with you
yeah we were - yeah okay that's it
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh no screams the
batsman and no football games is you
know best ball games you'd want TV I
can't see you can't see it vision sound
secure radio would do the trick for you
yeah - babies - hey looky a snooze UK
these news
yeah you we miss you so you have a
cellphone
no you have a bank account yes you do
hey are you saving money or you just
have enough just to get by
you guys you ready anything you'd like
to do in your life before before your
days are done
then he dreams any goals and like that
yeah hey I only think about you as a Big
Apple you I go to New York
yeah let's go then yeah New York's a
great city
I think there I never do before dinner
and you've been still like we're laying
snow you are seeing the snow
I think it's not like I'm stupid and I
like it didn't real cold out there in
today
yeah it's called a [ __ ] yeah in the
winter yeah people fall through endure
that is that well that's that's when
it's extreme cold yeah yeah you got a
driver's license or some good ID to get
on a plane
hey okay so you need I'm gonna take you
to New York
y'all go to New York with me yeah we
could come to you I'm sorry a passport
to denieth occur to you I need a
passport to go to another country
no your passwords do I'm sorry it's hard
to do Passport no it's easy to get a
passport okay they call that I don't
think so the owner will get you a
passport I'll take you to Costa Rica
with me
you figure out where you want to go I'll
take you on a trip
anything with a bigger boot bags Oh
crazy these guys gotta tell me okay they
big oh yeah
you're gonna cruise or use my going to
vote pretty cool you were gonna cruise
like for a week-long cruise to Mexico or
through Hawaii whatever who's with them
well they're cool trip by the tens Mike
Michael - Michael you can't think of it
those yeah we do everything oh yeah
their beds if you can eat like a king
for the whole week you put on about 10
15 pounds yeah you wanna do that
yeah I'll pass on that I don't like that
I feel trapped on a cruise ship
yes sir no I'm not a surfer though I've
done it I've tried it I'm not good at it
and then see you guys to like you see
that's it was besides TV you've been to
the beach I'm gonna be ten yeah besides
TV I see somebody else so go and see my
suit anything in LA you want to see hey
you're up here so you need I'm sorry
so do you collect a disability income
every month yes and what how much is
that that word is nice but may be fitted
into it how much give you those plates
Anu yeah I think you said it like three
hundred times yeah and then how is your
health
that you good what's the matter have COP
what is that oh yeah Kuwait obstructed
no disease all right
it'll take a little bit you see oh yeah
yo P quality up disease yeah I see
you're carrying there's devices here
like that dad to keep me breathing kiddo
they do go be the walkers we would say
time especially on a hot day I do a
really gets me yeah yeah hey well
understand something that and that had
nothing to do with your shoot
no there's just something that you have
yeah the Brian is midline they work they
I can't see your face your vision is so
blurry right yeah boo boo yeah so what's
the most extreme reaction you've ever
seen from people on the street hey Louie
to Lucy like like somebody that sees you
and thinks that this has a negative
reaction to to to you the kids you guys
think it over
yeah kids like that it's two kids like
that yeah I think the kids can sense
your your energy and your even hurt a
flea
yeah nice yeah and they just asked me
right up front what's going on yeah
where's adults are afraid to talk right
right yeah let me think boy I just do it
that you're very aware very intelligent
they don't want to get to know you yeah
touch me play out that they never
thought I would make it man
do you think maybe people's reaction to
you is what it is because it's too hard
for them to process how unfair what
happened to you is do whatever doing no
but but but it's not this they don't
know but if they actually understood how
you were robbed of so much it's hard
it's hard for a person to process that
and deal with so it's easier just to
ignore you or first yeah file you away
and not look at you yeah ignore you
rather than your act and get to know you
let the flower right over the homeless
lady nothing there's a boy walk back she
tell the boy to look at those recorded
over get him oh [ __ ] oh don't look at
that look over there yeah that's what
kids they wait hey I do it everything
they really sweet the tragedy of that is
you're letting the kindest nicest person
I've ever met
kids are amazing
one guy came to talk to me I think in
that video you say but see me instruct
you in ICU this video whatever to you
and if you really can't you talk to me
yeah something to your boy like this
mm-hm so then you're a tween and I will
28 yeah surgical so what is your view on
gun laws who good those guns dangers I
like him we did it good middle period
say what I'm gonna hear the Rope UAH say
it one more time they gave you the wrong
people here are they getting the wrong
people's hands
yeah yeah cuz it's very dangerous but
they just go by him in a row and yet
there is a net but they still out there
still I did then I said you are they
stopped making those little small ones
the - oh you're here it's I think it was
like thinking driveability who they are
I don't know it's going to cool if you
take a little music for shoes and stuff
like that drive-by shooting so do your
mom
contact info your phone number the do
you have your mom's phone number and
then move to it you you want to give her
a call sometime
yeah well you will you call yeah you got
to yeah let me know and I'll say yeah
okay
I'll put her on the phone for you
definitely yeah you don't have a phone
right Lulu
so what words of wisdom would you give
people if you wanted to finish this off
with with one little bit of wisdom from
Jerry can you cook you got that's it
it's too late
it hit me to everything can't believe
you you three of all things possible no
matter what you're always staying with
you live anyway
sure you had breakfast yet do you wanna
go get breakfast somewhere yeah yeah
yeah he's a sandwich
you